[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for The Developer Show.
Now this is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Stick around to the
end for highlights
from Google Cloud Next.
But first, Android P
beta 4 is now available.
It's the final preview
update before we
launch the official Android
P platform later this summer,
and includes a release
candidate build
with final system behaviors and
the official Android P APIs.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below to wrap up your testing in
time for the official release.
Chrome 68 is now available
and includes several updates
for developers, including add
to home screen changes, the page
lifecycle API, the payment
handler API, and more.
Details are on the post.
Dialogflow recently introduced
several new beta features
to expand conversational
capabilities for customer
support and contact centers.
Head on over to the post
for details and screenshots
of knowledge connectors,
automatic spelling correction,
and phone gateway.
The Go team at Google recently
released a new open source
project called Go Cloud.
It's a library and tools for
developing on the open cloud
to help you build portable
cloud applications.
Take a look at the post
for details of how it works
and how to get involved.
Google Cloud Next
2018 was last week
in San Francisco, California.
There were a ton
of announcements.
Here's just a few highlights.
Cloud Build is a fully managed,
continuous integration,
and continuous
delivery platform that
lets you build and
test applications
in the cloud at scale.
We're connecting GitHub with
Cloud Build to provide fast,
frictionless, and convenient CI
for any repository on GitHub.
Updates to our
serverless compute stack
include new App Engine
runtimes, Cloud Functions
general availability,
and serverless containers
on Cloud Functions.
New database features along
with partnerships, beta news,
and other improvements
can help you get
the most out of your databases.
Transparent SOIs, or
Service Level Indicators,
give you fine-grained
detail about the behavior
of Google Cloud
Platform services
as related to your workloads.
And BigQuery ML, which is a new
capability inside BigQuery that
enables you to build
and deploy machine
learning models on massive
structured or semi-structured
datasets.
There was a lot more,
but don't worry if you
couldn't be at the event.
Just head on over to the
Google Cloud YouTube channel
linked to in the
description below
for all the keynote
and session videos.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
You know you need
unique New York.
Rubber baby buggy bumpers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]